FOR LETTING BAD ACTORS, LIKE
RUSSIA SLIDE WHILE TAKING SHARP
AIM AT SOME OF OUR ALLIES.
>> Brett: DENUCLEARIZATION AND A
BIG PART OF THAT IS KIM JONG-UN.
I TALKED WITH THE SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT EARLIER TODAY.
YESTERDAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
BEFORE THE SIGNING OF THE NEW
TRADE AGREEMENT SAID THIS.
>> A LOT OF POSITIVE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING WITH SHERMAN KIM OF
NORTH KOREA.
>> Brett: DO YOU EXPECT A LOT OF
POSITIVE THINGS BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM?
>> THROUGH THE SUMMIT MEETING WE
HAD ACHIEVED PROGRESS ON
DENUCLEAR SRI --IZATION AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO A MEETING WITH
KIM AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE
NEAR FUTURE.
>> Brett: BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR?
>> YES, I BELIEVE SO.
>> Brett: THERE IS CONCERN IN
THE U.S. THAT MAYBE TOO MUCH IS
BEING GIVEN UP BEFORE ACTUAL
DENUCLEARIZATION IS HAPPENING IN
NORTH KOREA.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT?
>> THERE IS A LOT OF SPECULATION
IF NORTH KOREA WILL ACTUALLY
KEEP THEIR PROMISE THIS TIME.
HOWEVER, I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
AGREEMENT THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
IS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WE HAVE IN THE PAST.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE LEADER OF NORTH
KOREA FRESH OUT OF A SMUMENT
MEETING AND THEY MADE A PROMISE
IN FRONT OF THE WHOLE WORLD THAT
IS BINDING AND THEY HAVE A LOT
OF RESPONSIBILITY ON THEIR
SHOULDER.
NORTH KOREA CAN ONLY HAVE
SANCTIONS RELIEF AFTER
DENUCLEARIZATION IS COMPLETED.
AS FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE NEEDS
TO SOLVE THE NORTH KOREA NUCLEAR
PROBLEM AND THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT NOBODY HAS BEEN ABLE TO
SOLVE IN THE DECADES PAST.
SO, HE WILL HAVE A MAJOR
ACHIEVEMENT.
>> Brett: WHAT IS YOUR TOP
PRIORITY?
>> PEACE AND I HOPE THAT
UNIFICATION WILL COME NATURALLY,
AS WELL.
>> Brett: WHAT IS YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE
IT?
>> EVER SINCE MY INAUGURATION
LAST MAY, I HAD SEVEN SUMMIT
MEETINGS WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT HAVE
BECOME MORE THAN A FRIEND WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND BETWEEN THE
TWO OF US, THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
PER -- PERFECT TRUST.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ACCOMPLISHED
IN TERMS OF NORTH KOREA'S
DENUCLEARIZATION AND THE CHANGES
IN PLACE FROM NINE MONTHS AND
LAST NOVEMBER AND IF YOU COMPARE
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID AT THE
UN GENERAL ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR.
>> ROCKET MAN IS ON A SUICIDE
MISSION FOR HIMSELF AND HIS
REGIME.
>> AND TODAY.
>> TREMENDOUS PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE AND I THINK THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE AN OUTCOME.
>> EVER SINCE LAST NOVEMBER,
NORTH KOREA HAS NOT ENGAGED IN
ANY NUCLEAR TEST OR
PROVERYCATIONS OF THIS TIME.
AND THEY HAVE DISPANT
AND THEY HAVE DISPAN
AND THEY HAVE DISMAN
AND THEY HAVE DISMANT
AND THEY HAVE DISMANTLE
AND THEY HAVE DISMANTLED
AND THEY HAVE DISMANTLED T
AND THEY HAVE DISMANTLED THE
AND THEY HAVE DISMANTLED THEIR
NUCLEAR TEST SITE.
THIS IS THE ONLY NUCLEAR TEST
SITE THEY HAD.
THAT MEANS THEY WON'T HAVE A
SITE IN THE FUTURE.
AND WITH MY MEETING WITH KIM
JONG-UN, HE EXPRESSED HIS
WILLINGNESS TO DISMANTLE THE
PLATFORM UNDER AMERICAN EXPERTS.
THIS MEANS THAT NORTH KOREA WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO TEST LONG RANGE
MISSILES AGAIN.
NOW, ALL OF THIS MEANS THAT
NORTH KOREA WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
THREATEN THE UNITED STATES WITH
THEIR NUCLEAR MISSILE ARSENAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WILLING TO
TAKE ADDITIONAL MEASURES AND ALL
OF THIS CHANGE THAT WE ARE
WITNESSING RIGHT NOW IS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS THE FIRST EVER
SUMMIT WITH THE LEADER OF NORTH
KOREA IN 70 YEARS OF THEIR
HISTORY.
ALL OF MY PRAISE GOES TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Brett: SO YOU GIVE HIM A LOT
OF CREDIT?
>> YES.
>> Brett: YOU HAVE MET WITH KIM
JONG-UN MORE THAN MOST PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD.
HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE HIM?
HIS SENSIBILITIES?
IS HE SERIOUS?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT HE COULD
COMPLETELY DENUCLEARIZE THE
NORTH COMPLETELY OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS THE IDENTIFY
OF NORTH KOREA.
>> KIM JONG-UN HAS EXPECTATIONS
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SUCH A
MAJOR FEAT CAN ONLY BE ACHIEVED
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE WANTS TO ACHIEVE THE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH KOREA
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND THIS DESIRE ON MANY
OCCASIONS TOO.
IN ORDER TO MAKE PROGRESS HE
WANTS TO HAVE THE SECOND NORTH
KOREA SUMMIT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
I WOULD SAY THAT KIM JONG-UN IS
YOUNG AND CANDID AND HAS CLEAR
COMMITMENTS TO DENUCLEARIZATION
AND HE'S READY TO ABANDON HIS
NUCLEAR PROGRAM AND FOCUS ON
ECONOMIC BENEFITS INSTEAD, IN
ORDER TO HELP HIS PEEP.
-- PEOPLE.
HE HAS THIS STRATEGIC MIND.
>> Brett: DO YOU THINK THAT FULL
VERIFIABLE DENUCLEARIZATION, THE
GOAL OF 2021, THAT HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT, IS THAT REALISTIC?
IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT TO GO IN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
>> KIM JONG-UN IS WILLING TO
HAVE THE INTERNATIONAL
INSPECTORS INSPECT HIS
FACILITIES AND SAID THAT HE'S
READY TO PERMANENTLY DISABLE HIS
FACILITIES.
NOW, IF NORTH KOREA TAKES
GENUINE MEASURES IN TERMS OF
DISMANTLING THEIR NUCLEAR
PROGRAM, IT ALL COMES DOWN IF
THE UNITED STATES IS READY TO
PROVIDE CORRESPONDING MEASURES
IN A SWIFT WAY.
THE UNITED STATES PROMISED TO
END HOSTILE RELATIONS WITH NORTH
KOREA TO PROVIDE SECURITY
GUARANTEES AND WORK WITH NEW
U.S./KOREA RELATIONS.
ALTHOUGH THEY WILL NOT HAPPEN
SIMULTANEOUSLY, I BELIEVE THEY
NEED TO BE TAKEN IN PAIR HELL.
-- PAIR.
THIS IS WHY I FEEL IT IS
ACHIEVABLE DURING PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TERM.
>> Brett: DO YOU TRUST KIM
JONG-UN?
HE DOESN'T HAVE A GREAT TRACK
RECORD OF PROMISING AND
DELIVERING ON THINGS.
WHAT WE HEAR FROM THE U.S.
ADMINISTRATION IS THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THINGS DONE
COMPLETELY AND THEN, PULL THE
SANCTIONS OFF.
>> WHEN WE SAY, "COARSE PONDING
MEASURES" WE CAN THINK ABOUT THE
CHANGES
CHANGE
CHANGES -- THE CULTURE
CHANGES -- THE CULTUAL
EXCHANGES AND IF SO, WE CAN
THINK ABOUT ESTABLISHING A U.S.
LIAISON OFFICE AND BY
ESTABLISHING THIS KIND OF
OFFICE, WE CAN SHOW THE U.S.
COMMITMENT TO END HOSTILE
RELATIONS WITH NORTH KOREA AND
LOW GUESTICLY SUPPORT THE
ACTIVITIES.
AND EXTENDING THE ECONOMIC
RELATIONS WITH NORTH KOREA.
I CAN TELL YOU THERE IS NOTHING
TO LOSE FOR US WHEN WE PUT OUR
TRUST IN NORTH KOREA.
THE MEASURES THAT NORTH KOREA
WILL BE TAKING WILL BE THE
PERMANENT DISMANTLEMENT OF
NUCLEAR BASES AND IF THEY ARE
EXISTING AND NUCLEAR ARSENAL.
THESE ARE ALL IRREVERSIBLE
MEASURES.
THE MEASURES THAT THE U.S. WILL
BE TAKING IS THE SUSPENSION OF
JOINT MILITARY EXERCISES, WHICH
CAN BE RESUMED AT ANY TIME.
IF NORTH KOREA GOES BACK ON ITS
PROMISE, WE CAN PUT THESE
SANCTIONS ON AGAIN.
THE UNITED STATES HAS NOTHING TO
LOSE.
>> Brett: DID YOU IMAGINE SEEING
ONE KOREA IN YOUR LIFETIME?
>> IT IS HARD TO PREDICT WHEN
THAT CAN BE ACHIEVE.
WE CANNOT PLAN FOR THIS KIND OF
THING.
IF WE ESTABLISH COMPLETE PEACE,
WE CAN SEE THAT.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT I WILL SEE IT
IN MY LIFETIME.
>> Brett: DO YOU WANT TO SEE
U.S. TROOPS LEAVE SOONER THAN
LATER?
>> I WOULD SAY NO.
I COULD TELL YOU THAT THE U.S.
AND KOREA IS BENEFICIAL FOR THE
DETER RENT FOR NORTH KOREA AND
UPHOLDING PEACE AND STABILITY IN
THE NORTHEAST ASIAN REGION AS A
WHOLE.
EVEN AFTER DENUCLEARIZATION IS
ACHIEVED, I CAN SEE THE U.S.
TROOPS REMAIN IN KOREA FOR THE
PEACE AND STABILITY OF THE''.
I EXPECT THERE ARE GOING TO BE
PLENTY OF DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CHAIRMAN KIM
IN THE UPCOMING SUMMIT.
IT IS MY DESIRE TO
IT IS MY DESIRE T
IT IS MY DESIRE  T
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO S
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO SIG
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO SIGN
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO SIGN T
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO SIGN THI
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO SIGN THIS
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO SIGN THIS A
IT IS MY DESIRE  TO SIGN THIS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE THAT THE
TENSION BETWEEN NORTH KOREA AND
THE UNITED STATES HAVE ENDED.
>> Brett: I WANT YOU TO ADDRESS
SOME OF YOUR CRITICS IN KOREA
AND SOME POINTS.
THEY SAY THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
CLUMPING DOWN ON JOURNALISTS AND
MUZZLING FACTORS AND LIMITING
FREE SPEECH AND DEMOCRATIC
NORMS.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> I CAN TELL YOU OUT OF THE
ENTIRE HISTORY HERE, THE FREEDOM
OF SPEECH AND PRESS HAVE NEVER
BEEN GREATER THAN AT THIS TIME.
THE PRESS THAT YOU ARE SEEING IN
THE U.S. GOES UNPUNISHED, AS
WELL.
EVERY WEEKEND YOU CAN SEE IN THE
CROWN PLAZA, WHICH IS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF MY OFFICE, THE
ASSEMBLIES THAT HEAVILY
CRITICIZE ME HAPPEN EVERY
WEEKEND.
>> Brett: THE THEORY IS THAT YOU
ARE TRYING TO LINE THINGS UP AND
NOT TAKING IT OUT OF TEXT BOOKS
AND YOU SAY, IN THE WORDS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THAT'S ALL FAKE
NEWS.
>> OUR OBJECTION FOR ASPIRING
FOR UNIFICATION IS THE SAME
ACROSS ALL NATIONS.
AND THE PRESCRIPTION IS THAT WE
NEED TO WORK TOWARDS PEACEFUL RE
NEED TO WORK TOWARDS PEACEFUL  E
REUNIFICATION WITH NORTH KOREA
AND ONE OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES
AS A PRESIDENT.
AS FOR THE PEOPLE WHO CRITICIZE
ME, I CAN TELL YOU, MOST OF
THEM, FROM PAST ADMINISTRATIONS
ARE CALLING REUNIFICATION AS A